i have some beef officially um you like
are losing weight and covered every i
found it what are you doing spanx and
also
um you look so good i lost my taste and
smells oh that's right
so food is kind of different right now
oh my still yes so you had
so she had coveted if anybody didn't
know who did it but like that so wait
what was
you did you were one of the people that
lost all your yeah i so
yes about about five days in i'm like
honey cause garth makes my coffee every
morning i'm like i love you but did you
like is this this is weed coffee
i love you bud did you put coffee in
here and that it was just like that and
so it's been about
um eight weeks what yeah so i
it's really weird i think this is how
normal people eat so i think they eat
when they're hungry
this is my theory and then they they
stop when they're full
it's weird because it's so much about
taste
and smell and if you can't smell you
don't really crave
you don't you just don't and so and it's
all so now it's all about texture
i can tell if something's spicy um
that's about it
still lots of hot sauce but they say it
comes back
they do say it does kelly oh my gosh i
mean it's hard
cooking i love to cook so now when i
cook i just ask garth like
tell me if it needs more salt and pepper
you know oh my gosh
the weirdest thing that's the crit and
he didn't get it that's the weirdest
thing well he's an alien and i think we
proved this no yes we have but here's
the thing i actually know a few couples
where one person got it and the other
one
yeah and i'm like how does that happen
and he was not like
because i'm like you have to get away
from me like you have to quarantine
in another room and like no no we're in
this together i'm like honey
i cannot give garth brook's cove like
you can't get it
and he never did and he hadn't he had
the vaccine he didn't have any not even
a sore arm like he's just
he's just not oh i got so sick off mine
did you he's just for like 12 hours yeah
no he didn't get any of that so i just
don't think he's
i mean i knew he wasn't normal but he's
an alien well
did he take care of you was he a good
doctor he was really wonderful okay yeah
okay he was really great oh my god
that's how you know it's love because
i'd be like are you okay
in here well i was like if you get it
i'm not gonna be
i'm not gonna sleep in the bed with you
look i don't want to keep exchanging
this beautiful
i love you but no oh my gosh that's
amazing
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever